[Music]
in secret fortune news oh that's your
kids until they're 10 yep submitted by
JK come to Florida we had a secret
meeting agree that no one came to yeah
we were at the Fun Center the Golkar Fun
Center
did you know we had one had more people
that took pictures with us at the
[ __ ] go-kart center outside of the
thing yeah cuz our fears don't go to
playlist bro I know none of you guys
were there a 96 year old secretary
quietly amassed a fortune and donated
8.2 million dollars before passing how
did they slowly a massive fortune how
did she slowly amass oh my god woman and
basil me how's the secretary enough
eight million dollars it might be the
Secretary to oh whatever mine why did I
hear library what library librarian I
heard librarian secretary your
secretaries can make a [ __ ] ton cuz
imagine being a secretary to a
billionaire I mean and then learning or
like someone that's like real estate
genius and then they're like you have
such close proximity and it's like I
wanna learn some [ __ ] or have you seen
the movie with the secretary that like
she's into bondage and [ __ ] but dominant
dominatrix awesome on you geez yeah on
you just duck on a horn Yujin ya know
there's a movie like that dudes on what
it is but her boss like like whipster
and hopefully shades of grey
you're saying that best of all oh oh you
talkin about uh it's an old movie yeah
it's older older uh dildos in hats
dildos in hats
sister yeah Oh mater I'm sorry I [ __ ]
it all up I [ __ ] it all up
I'm sorry move it on no it's moving us
all the way I know I time-traveled in my
mind from Maggie Maggie what's that we
have to find out now just so I can go on
with my life usually the point of this
which one it's not the Secretary is it
that can't be it
I think it's called the secretary that
is the sorriest [ __ ] answer on earth
any see let me see
no I can't be there yes the secretary no
it's like we think about the same movie
sorry baby
I want to hear the article please yeah I
think I think I'm thinking of a
different movie any hi fine fine please
Antoine no it's called the secretary and
you wasted our time let's continue I
don't understand what the point was
me neither coz for life for life life
die
it is it is secretary I just do not
[ __ ] jail anyway it was type of the
secretary that amassed a fortune holy oh
my god I said move on five minutes ago
don't blame me blame those two please
David Lee hey I can't do it but you
started it oh that should pop that a
door for my vehicle alright so this
story is about Sylvia bloom she was a
legal secretary from Brooklyn uh-huh
she worked for the same law firm for 67
years until she retired at the age of 96
Oh
saving up yeah that's why I need to save
my pocket money with the law firm since
its inception well she was with the
first lawyers there now the cows yo how
much you want to bet though she's rich
because she doesn't have Amazon on her
[ __ ] phone no she doesn't
uber anywhere or post mates yeah [ __ ]
lady just cooks all her food at home and
[ __ ]
I just bought a whole [ __ ] diet in
2016 but just recently we learned that
she donated or that she cultivated him
almost or more than nine million dollars
Wow and so what she the way she ended up
having all this money it was because
back in the day in the early times when
secretaries they would actually handle
everything from their bosses so like
even personal things like personal
investments so she would she would then
look at what her boss would buy in stock
girl
and then like buy it for her boss and
then buy some for herself Wow that's
what I was saying
that's exactly what you said yeah she
probably learned a lot from having close
proximity to the billionaires that's one
of the factors another factor was the
fact that she just lived a very simple
and I think she would always take the
subway to work that's why you a Sian
she lived in her fallout with the Ford
Model T actually I said that was she
also she lived in a rent-controlled
apartment hmm
did she have kids read control I hate
that no wait that's why I mean I mean I
like it when I'm the one renting but it
controls it jack up the price on days
where it it I don't have that [ __ ] man
[ __ ] sucks she did not need it you
should not have kids cuz I'm gonna own
an apartment complex one day and I'm
gonna be like you [ __ ] but then it's
like but then it's like what's the point
you know I'm saying like what's the
point of saving all that money guys
exactly what my mom told me yeah she was
like [ __ ] but like yeah she say those
money but she's donated all cuz she's
about to die I mean I don't know if that
was her like her life gold or just have
a bunch of money that don't know maybe
she was just say
for a rainy day in that rainy day never
came in she's like ah [ __ ] now that
sucks that's a really rainy day 9
million but it doesn't sound like she
like worked her like fingers to the bone
this is it's New York she probably did
she yeah it also sounds like she likes
what she was doing because she worked
until she was 97 she probably liked her
simple life too I mean you know she
could have retired 30 years before date
she was married her her husband was a
firefighter he retired and became a city
schoolteacher with the pharmacist career
on the side I'm just straight hustlers
yeah and then so she ended up keeping
her name which was indicative of her
independent nature because they're
saying that it's quite possible that her
husband didn't even know that she had
all this money because all that money
was like on that's the old-school thing
you do yeah
what's the old school thinking uh women
always have to have their own account
secret hidden underneath the mattress
that's why cuz because the [ __ ]
husband would have a gambling addiction
and go into her account and then use it
all of that stuff or just leave er yeah
they're not stranded by themselves yep
and they're independent cuz back in the
day like women didn't really have a lot
of job options you know when they just
got a suit get some money
suing wasn't popular back like this I'm
deleting Amazon off my [ __ ] tonight do
you that was on that would you're too
addicted man I use it way too it's like
Christmas what do you would you buy I
bought fat wood sticks so when I go
camping even though I have a lighter and
then I also bought a Ferro rod so I
could make sparks today it's oh that's
dope I want to get that too so I'm
saying man I understand but the stupid
[ __ ] is like we have even re-using yeah
I actually started lighting hella [ __ ]
on fire for no reason in the house and
then my roommates got mad at me
so um because it started smelling like
campfire but I supposed to do that
outside yeah but I put it under the
stove and I had the [ __ ] I'm sounding
like you right now you don't sound like
me
but I find use a lighter yeah I'll be do
it on our front lawn yeah
enough manual fires to know that
lighters are a [ __ ] blessing so I I
definitely learned that lighters are
blessing like it's it's pretty cool
though that just in case some [ __ ]
happens me see oh nothing's gonna happen
cuz you should just drive down the
campsite mister I bought myself a nice
little small night that he called me a
[ __ ] and then I fell all self-conscious
so I bought a bigger night it wasn't the
size of the brand it was shitty did it
matter if it was a bread because the
knife's still worse he calling it a
knife is it a no yeah so now I have I
bought this [ __ ] Kershaw [ __ ] war
yes Kershaw has a good brain and it's
like the suck it's like the size of this
got a war log yeah it's pretty awesome
weird like a bowie knife no so the the
Warthog is is a super utility knife
where it can also be used like split
wood but it's just small enough where
you can still like like butterfly your
[ __ ] or shave your beard basically like
shave time your sticks so it's like it's
a little good mix of both so you don't
have to carry a match at day and also
you keep so cool your knives yeah but
then but you don't [ __ ] you what got me
into it making it afraid I know I'll
just gonna say that just gonna say that
I kept watching that [ __ ] I was like
dude if I'm ever in a situation I don't
know what all those up bro mean I'm a
kidney yeah of course the problem might
be the Tesla is gonna leave me stranded
probably easier to find gas and
electricity for sure yeah but that's my
god the Honda Element
and I'm taking it over there you know
Tesla needs to come out with like a
solar chargers for stranded days it
would be great if they just put a solar
planet on the car I never use a Sun roof
but the light that comes in through it
is really nice
yeah I have a convertible I haven't put
the top down in like two years yes it's
in a minute yeah it's just such a hassle
because they
that's like 20 seconds 20 seconds of my
precious lights I could barely watch a
[ __ ] Instagram storix um I uh see
forever oh that's different yeah not any
all girls I'm like mm-hmm
actually everybody just some no thanks
well I mean why do you watch it yeah you
too I just for the Instagram story I
just leave it and I just let it play can
I just watch it like that
do you yeah why I don't know I think
it's because I feel like people put
effort into their stuff and if I follow
them I'm fall in there for a reason so I
should you watch my stories yeah I watch
all your stories it's Tiger all the time
it's [ __ ] great
oh I love that child I'm gonna stop
doing my story no I watch your stories
they even comment on that last picture I
know I'm being dumb Anika watch the way
sometimes it songs talking [ __ ] you know
I actually like it's the stories more
than the actual post same why I'm so
dynamic I like it way more y'all know
the reasons why people want YouTube
videos anyone oh [ __ ] um I watch a lot
of I still watch youtube videos though
like I watch all the KC nice that stuff
all the way through
yeah I don't I don't even [ __ ] know
wide like he's just talking about some
regular [ __ ] he's a good ass water
it's just charismatic as [ __ ] man I
don't know what it is about him dude I
love that guy's gremlin [ __ ] god I
love him so fancy my hip - sunglasses
yeah something about him dude oh you're
not chipped he designs them that way
my butt is paint over it and then he
scratches it off does he he made me
change they'll be like brand-new radians
sprays him down yeah Dan cuz I just
thought his [ __ ] sunglasses were used
so much that it got weathered like a
[ __ ] he creates it himself
well damn man that looked [ __ ] up he
likes to [ __ ] up things before it
doesn't even look like this dressed like
on purpose like this dress jeans yeah
yeah yeah it just looks like oh he is
healing in a bunch of [ __ ] pain it
looked like yeah the the glasses has
seen some [ __ ] yeah okay see
[Music]
[Music]